[Music]  yale class  of 2021 congratulations samantha power  here i've been asked to keep it short  and keep it fun  if anyone knows how to keep it short and  fun it's me  the author of a 700 page book on  genocide  but in all seriousness i hope you  graduate today with a heart full of  pride  a head full of smarts and a commitment  to defend dignity wherever you go  yours and that of the people in the  world less fortunate than you  covet 19 has taken so much from us but  it's also given us something  a broadened sense of empathy this is a  rare moment in time when everyone on  planet earth  has had their lives changed together  we all got a lesson in what essential  really means  and as you leave yale today and this  pandemic breaks  i urge you not to lose that empathy  your concern for a world outside of your  own  is the key to living that big fulfilling  life that you seek  congratulations yale class of 2021